less than a year ago and the one planet
summit in Paris we launched together our
pilot partnership between the European
Commission and the breakthrough Energy
Coalition and today we the public and
and private investors are showing that
we walk the talk in order to catalyze
investment in Europe or breakthrough
innovation this investment fund of 100
million euros it's first-of-a-kind
and it was set up in a record time and
it really demonstrates a new approach to
public-private partnership if we look at
the world as a whole the total amount of
energy used over the next 50 years is
going to double and we want economies to
grow the amount of steel cement food
meat that gets produced globally that is
going to increase but at the same time
we need to slash global emissions well
how can that be done well the answer is
definitely innovation and my history of
Microsoft you know maybe an optimist a
believer in backing scientists to solve
very tough problems and here in Europe
there's an incredible number of
scientists who've got good ideas
I'm the commitment of breakthrough
energy is through this partnership to
build a team here and find those good
ideas but that's just the start you want
to fund the research and then you want a
lot of those people to be building
companies and partnering with the
existing companies and a lot of these
areas we're really counting on on Europe
to lead the way today is the next step
the next step of our relationship and
the fact that you were keen to work with
us again it's extraordinary in 2015 in
cop21 we made a commitment to come
together and protect our world for the
generations to come and since then we've
been talking about the public and the
private sectors joining forces and
that's where things really get tough is
to put the public and the private
working
and so the public does its own thing the
private does their own thing but we have
to work together if you want to solve
the problem the reality is that in
politics sometimes you do these speeches
and you have inspired people but then
you need action and and I think once
Bill Gates said that vision without
execution is daydreaming and today is
not about daydreaming
we are doing something together which is
to pull these money in between the
European Union and private investors led
by Bill Gates